complete madness has taken hold in the  United States not only do we have armed  individuals near and around many drop  boxes ballot drop boxes in Arizona  we increasingly are hearing from local  election officials people who actually  are working the upcoming elections on  Tuesday  who are afraid for their own safety they  are afraid that so-called monitors or  Watchers or different people are going  to show up  and they're not going to like how  they're running the election  some of them we know carry firearms and  the poll workers are increasingly scared  what a horrible situation we  increasingly have in this country